got a couple of days if you want to put  money into an i Bond and get 9.62  percent annual interest and the big  print says  anything it's amazing and yeah it is  amazing if I could get 9.6 on a  six-month CD I would take it but that's  not the terms on this it's 9.6 for six  months on a one-year Bond and you know  what the last six months are no you  don't because they don't tell you until  later it's a variable interest rate  product with long-term implications and  heavy  fees for cashing out early so it's not a  good short-term product and it doesn't  make enough to be a long-term product  because I can make a lot more than 962  on average investing in good mutual  funds because you just got to read to  learn to look at these things a little  more carefully and once you realize all  the gotchas then you go well it's just  not as sexy as it sounds